this video is sponsored by opera gx the
free internet browser tailored
specifically to gamers
if you're like me and you play games
while using a browser like google chrome
you'd be surprised at how many resources
chrome steals from your pc
opera gx solves this first and foremost
and lets you limit the processing power
or ram or bandwidth you'd like your
browser to use
it also has its fabulous sidebar which
lets you do so many things like log into
spotify or youtube music via its gx
player and play anything you'd like to
from those services there's also the
integrated twitch app which lets you
watch your favorite streamers without
opening a new tab and integrated
chatting apps like discord or even
twitter and instagram
the entire browser is completely
customizable as well with some pretty
sweet neon lights custom wallpapers and
even optional sound effects and
background
music opera gx even has the quick import
tool so you can import all your
bookmarks all your browsing history and
yes
all the cookies oh and the cherry on top
is that it has a built-in vpn and ad
blocker
like i said it's completely free so
honestly i recommend doing yourself a
favor
following the link in the description
below and switching your browser to
opera gx
like i did and now on to the video
hey everyone bandit here don't you just
love girohim he's got that swoopy hair
those weird clothes and that
tongue flailing thing he's just so
lovable you know with the recent release
of skyward sword hd it's got me thinking
about a lot of the characters in that
game
namely the one-off villain known as
girohim well actually his status as a
one-off villain is what this entire
video is about or in other words what if
girohim has actually been spotted in
other zelda games and we just didn't
know it
even breath of the wild by the way there
are definitely going to be spoilers
for skyward swords ending in this video
so consider yourself warned of said
spoilers
also i have another very special message
for some very special people at the end
of this video so you want to stick
around for that but back to girohim
let's recap his role in skyward sword
real quick
girohim is first introduced to us as the
seemingly all-powerful demon lord who
for whatever reason is chasing zelda
around
trying to nab her for evil purposes
which he eventually does do
but only after link and company managed
to defeat the demon lord's demon lord
demise also known as the imprisoned also
known as the avocado
of death girihim takes zelda through the
portal of time into the past in order to
zap her goddess powers out of her body
and into his masters
once again he is successful in this
venture even though link very pleasantly
beats him half to death
when demise busts out of his death
avocado form and emerges as his original
humanoid form he decides that girohim's
time in humanoid form is all
used up and girhim then turns into his
master's
sword a master sword if you will demise
who is now joined by his trusty dark
master sword is immediately challenged
by a rather t
owed link and the two of them go off
into another realm to determine the fate
of the world by trying to resolve
their differences and peacefully talk
things out nah i'm just kidding they
fight to the death link is victorious
because he's amazing and then a very
weakened demise
thrusts his master sword which he
apparently is now too weak to wield or
something
into the ground and shortly after this
something very peculiar happens
the dark master sword otherwise known as
the demon lord girohim dissolves into
thin
air dot dot dot and that's it that's the
end of giroheem's story as
we know it for the past 10 years since
the game originally released what
happened to him has been debated and
theorized about since as we all know
nobody ever really dies forever in
fantasy games or movie franchises
at least not very commonly with
girohim's death being speculated over
for quite some time now
i'm going to go over some of the
possible answers that people have come
up with so far
and then a new one that i'd like to
bring to the table first and foremost it
is completely possible and even
somewhat obvious that the dark master
sword's dissolution into thin
air is simply due to demise's impending
death since the goddess sword and by
extension the sword spirit phi
were created by the goddess hylia and
since demise is credited with being the
creator of all demons across the entire
franchise it can be assumed that the
dark master sword and by extension the
demon lord girohim were created by
demise as well
logically speaking if demise meets his
own demise his power would cease to
exist right i mean
impa even states that demise is decaying
to nothingness within the master sword
that would easily explain the fact that
giroheim just dissolved away into thin
air and out of existence
except for one teeny tiny huge little
detail
see it makes sense that demise's power
would go away once he dies
but if it did truly disappear then
what's this
or this or all of these due to the
existence of demise's power later in the
franchise and the curse that demise
places on the goddess hylia and even
link himself before he got thanos
snapped into the master sword
clearly we know that demise's power
didn't disappear
at least not entirely in addition to
that the dark master sword appears to
dissolve quite some time before the
master sword begins to glow
which it did to signify that it was
ready to vacuum up all of demise's
essence
also the dark master sword dissolves in
the opposite direction of link further
implying that giroheim did not enter the
master sword along with demise
and since girohim definitely did
dematerialize right here at the end of
skyward sword is it instead possible
that he didn't actually
cease to exist but maybe just ran away
and returned to the surface
what if he re-materialized somewhere
else in the series
enter possibility 2 which is to state
that girohim has
indeed returned potentially multiple
times over multiple different games as
the different weapons that ganon uses
this is what most theories about what
happened to giroheim usually end up with
concluding the typical answer normally
ends up being that he has most recently
manifested as ganon's trident when you
look at the series from the perspective
of its timeline
this is mostly speculation of course but
if giroheim had truly survived the
defeat of his master
it makes sense that he would want to
serve his master's reincarnation as
a weapon which is what he was always
meant to be according to his own words
furthermore and i realized that the
hyrule warriors games aren't canon but
in the first game
both ganondorf swords of demise and the
trident of demise weapons are named
after
you guessed it demise having weapons
associated with demise automatically
implies a giroheim connection and if
this is true then we even have a
potential return of girohim in breath of
the wild too
since we've seen in the sequel's first
trailer that ganondorf used to wield a
trident
honestly i have nothing against this
possibility for girohim's fate it's just
as plausible as any other speculation
out there in my opinion and if you've
been here on my channel for very long
you probably know by now that i love to
speculate which is exactly what brings
me to the final possibility
possibility number three what if girohim
is the curse you know the curse
the one that demise spoke into existence
right before he died
think about it something weird happened
when demise uttered his final words and
that
is that nothing happened actually
nothing flashy or spectacular whenever
he's used his powers before
it's always been big grandeur purple
blasts or red glowing essences or
something but here when he apparently
uttered the most
impactful words in the entire franchise
he just kind of
said the curse words and then laughed
and then died but what if nothing
happened because his words were just
words but
he still laughed about it because he
knew that he had already set the curse
in motion
just a few moments before when he stood
back up following that final stab from
link in the master sword
when he knew he was bested demise very
deliberately
raised his master sword into the air and
then stabbed it into the ground beside
him
now earlier in the video i said that
this was because he was too weak to hold
the sword any longer but if you think
about it when people are too weak to
hold things
they drop them not raise them into the
air and stab them into the ground which
would actually require some strength to
do
what if this was demise issuing a final
command
to his second in command to girohim who
is already pretty used to carrying out
his master's will for an unknown amount
of time all the while awaiting his
master's return
what if he told him to return to the
surface and build up power to summon his
reincarnation
or something like that demise's power
normally takes on a dark purple
coloration whenever he's using it
and that's exactly what girohim
dissolved into after demise stabbed him
into the ground
also in the original japanese version of
the game as some fans already know
demise calls this curse the curse of the
demon tribe
not just the curse of demise which
implies that there are more demons
involved than just himself
this could be a reference to the
incarnations of demise to come or
it could be referencing girhim who at
this point should already be carrying
out his master's eternal will
and what if in demise's final moments he
gave the rest of his power
to girohim like the power to create
other demons or other incarnations
of himself this transfer of power is
something that we know he should be able
to do since one of his incarnations
ganon is able to give a portion of his
own power to zant and twilight princess
if demise gave girihim his power and
sent him away
this would finally explain the curse of
the demon tribe which has most recently
and most
famously been materialized as malice in
breath of the wild
that's right this theory is implying
that girohim the right-hand man
demon lord and ultimate tool of demise
is responsible for carrying out demise's
will of hatred over the entire franchise
and dozens of millennia later has
materialized as
malice the sentient evil embodiment of
demise's malicious hatred
but of course this is all just what i
think what do you guys think is girihim
the key to solving the curse of the
demon tribe when he was sent away in a
purple mist of power at the end of the
game
or is this just another case of the
crazies let me know in the comments
below
also thank you so much for watching if
you enjoyed this video please consider
leaving a like below as that greatly
assists in getting it spread around on
youtube to other people who might also
enjoy it and subscribe if you haven't
already for much more awesome nintendo
stuff to come
it takes less than two seconds to do and
you can always unsubscribe if you feel
led to in the future and as i mentioned
earlier i have a message for some very
special people and
that would be the people who have
subscribed to my co-channel bandit plays
seriously i was hoping to maybe get like
a thousand subscribers over there in a
week if i was
lucky but within a few days you guys
more than doubled that number
thank you guys so much from the bottom
of my heart i'm so excited to start
making content over there it's been a
little bit slow to start because as i'm
sure you can tell
i've moved recently which means things
have been pretty hectic the past couple
weeks
like my ac breaking in my new apartment
in the texas summer but if you're
interested in seeing me play some games
real soon head on over to bandit plays
and click that subscribe button i'll
link to the channel in the description
below also of course
huge thanks goes out to all of my bandit
crew of which i have a new member to
announce
please say hello to link iora who
recently joined up right here on youtube
and i'm sorry about the pronunciation
there if you're interested in helping
these videos get made right here on the
channel please feel free to check out
that join button located below any video
or the links to my patreon or merch
pages in the description below also down
there my social media pages so come
follow me on
instagram and twitter and all that good
stuff for some more good stuff that's
all i've got in this one so as always i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day
this is masentana bandit looking forward
to seeing you in the next one and
signing out
[Music]
you